um yo talk to me about your verse on uh
wild thoughts which is one of like it's
probably my favorite as top three or
four calorie record for me it's a
[ __ ] smash obviously you and Riri
going back and forth your verse though
is like the verse that like if you're
mixing on the air
like you have to play the like your
versus the verse to play really my verse
always gets cut out every time no but
that's because people are lit the DJs
are lazy the DJs that know like you
gotta kind of cut ahead into the record
and play The Bryson version I feel like
your versus the quotables like shout out
to you man for for playing well I know a
lot of DJs who play that's the version I
feel like you gotta you kind of like
have the version where actually there's
like in DJ pools there's versions of
that record where it's just the hook
and then your verse and then the hook
and then it's you know for for DJs yeah
interesting you're not aware about this
about your own verse that it's like a
thing oh yeah not classic first man it
was uh it was an interesting for sure I
thank you but um I just wish
I wish I could have went uh differently
but hey man how could it have gone
differently I just wish I mean because
uh I just needed I wanted to like you
know get Rihanna's energy I didn't get
to hear what she did well I heard it
through a FaceTime call but like I
wanted to hear it yeah so what was the
process of that record like it was party
next door who wrote the song okay party
next uh I went to college place we had
dinner
um it invites me to the studio I always
tell them it's like bro you don't never
have to give me a whole spiel about a
song like you just played a song and
they're like let's go but he always
gives me this whole like he's like yeah
no don't let kids start selling cars
it's over nah for real yeah so then he
played this song and I was just like I'm
honestly bro you could just you didn't
have to say nothing like this is
obviously a smash you know what I'm
saying thank you for even wanting to
include me you said you wanna put who on
it Rihanna oh yeah definitely thank you
um but he wanted he was like yo we need
the verse tonight though or something
like that and I was just like I I mean
but ain't she gonna have to I'm gonna
have to pitch it up so you know I mean
Rihanna sings in a higher octave he was
like now we just need tonight and I'll
just like all right cool so I did the
verse but you know when I'm writing the
verse to like that matching party's
energy you know I mean it's kind of hard
to like imagine what's going on like I
would have just liked to do a little bit
more vocals you know what I mean
probably would have changed a couple
lyrics man yeah I just thought I was you
know song called wild thoughts I'm gonna
just say the wildest [ __ ] that I can
think of wildest the wildest thoughts
you know that's fair yeah and then in
that era it could have been about wild
thoughts as well wild thoughts yeah that
was like when everybody was saying the
word oh yeah I still say that word yeah
is that is that still you know thoughts
maybe not as much but it's definitely
definitely a word it's in my vocabulary
shout out to the Thotties Tatiana Ali's
out there yeah I mean what's down